what is up everybody at Santa Mac and
welcome to another episode of the week's
best anime videos where you can come to
catch up and all the fun stuff that you
missed in the past week the links to all
the videos are in the description and if
you have a recommendation just leave it
in the comments this past Thursday we
streamed the very first episode of r &
cafe right here on our channel and we
had a great time talking about anime for
guys versus anime for girls if such a
thing even exists we had an awesome time
talking with all you guys in the chat
thank you for coming out special thanks
to Mackel not simply rose and Brent from
brent's fandoms for being our special
guests and a big thank you to one master
who stayed up till 1am so that he can
watch the stream live from Finland for
those of you guys who were upset that
you could make it to the livestream
don't worry you can still watch the full
video just follow the link in the
description and we have a brand new
episode of r & cafe coming out this week
on thursday at 5pm same time as last
week so try to make it it'll be a great
time this week we're going to be
discussing all the enemy versus new
anime we're gonna have Mackel not simply
rose and Bryn from brent's fandoms back
as our guests and we're gonna have
another special guest briggs from all
day anime so that's gonna be really cool
be sure to drop in and chat with us and
feel free to let us know what you want
to talk about TeamFourStar uploaded
episode 56 of their dragon ball z
abridged series this week and there was
a lot of drama in this one mostly sexual
drama between goku and chichi once again
this episode was really funny and
definitely worth your time and we even
got to see den they go on a power trip
which was pretty awesome on Thursday
misty connects ya posted the very first
episode of his indie anime series
connect SIA and the eight seals this is
an independent crowd funded project and
misty has been working on and I have to
say right off the bat I really respect
him from taking on such an ambitious
project and following through with it
you can definitely tell that they were
working on a very tight budget and a
short time frame and Misty will be the
first to admit it but I definitely
respect them for taking on such a
massive task and if you're a fan of
indie projects definitely check this out
if you love aki dearest and the enemy
man you might want to know that they
uploaded a joint Q&A video this week if
you're a big fan of these guys you
should probably check out this video
because you will find out a lot of
information about their personal lives
including some stuff you pro
didn't want to know but if you are
interested in them and their personal
lives this video is definitely worth
your time I only recently discovered
youtuber Roger Smith 2004 and this week
he uploaded a video about history in
anime and more specifically he uploaded
a video about ghost slayers aya she and
western learning in this video he talks
about japanese isolationism and
suspicion of Westerners in the 19th
century and how this is portrayed in the
anime gold Slayers I 'she which came out
in 2006 he also looks at why the subject
matter that the anime deals with was
still relevant in 2006 and why it's
actually still relevant today and since
I'm a big fan of both history and anime
I really enjoyed this video youtuber
fruity RL is being featured for the
second time on our list for one of his
AMVs and this time it's a fairy tale and
we called heads and tails fairy tale is
one of the most popular anime and manga
series in the world and fruity RL
definitely doesn't justice with this amv
check it out another AMV youtuber makes
her list for the second time this week
warlocks and v's makes our list for a
Black Lagoon AMV called Falling Skies
now viewer discretion is advised for
this one because it features a lot of
brutal violence from the Black Lagoon
anime including the two creepiest
characters in the history of anime in my
opinion two twin children who are also
brutal assassins I noticed that warlocks
envies releases a new AMV every single
day and there are all very high quality
so if you're a big am V fan definitely
check out his channel and that is it for
this week guys if you enjoy these videos
be sure to LIKE and subscribe and until
next time see you space cowboys
you